a 48 hours investigation uncovers
disturbing new details in the murder for
hire case of a Minnesota teenager for
more than two years Peter van zan has
been on a journey through the dark web
investigating websites that advertised
hitman for hire his 2018 report click
for killer exposed about 20 active
murder plots he's here now with the
stunning results of an all-new 48 hours
global investigation I'm no different
than any other teenager in America in
July 2018 teenager alexis stern was
driving near her home in Big Lake
Minnesota when she got a shocking call
from police someone wanted her dead I
was like this is a joke right
it wasn't a joke authorities told her
that a person codenamed mastermind 365
had gone to a murder-for-hire website on
the dark web to have her killed the site
was run by a shadowy figure who calls
himself Yura he sent us some videos you
can submit your orders to kill the
people you hate looking for criminals on
the dark web like Yura is not for the
faint of heart we hired this dark web
intelligence analyst who we called Lisa
to begin a worldwide search to find
Europe
Alexis believes her ex-boyfriend
Adrienne Frey an English video gamer
hate Europe for her murder
Alexis says Adrienne visited her three
times in Minnesota and was deeply in
love
he was already pretty much talking about
getting married honestly she broke it
off and says he was angry pretty much
saying you deserve everything horrible
that happens to you Adrienne has denied
he tried to hire a hitman our dark web
investigation has taken us from England
to Moldova in Eastern Europe as well as
India and eventually back to the US our
analyst Lisa found a dark web password
among other clues that could link Europe
to a family in Queens New York there's a
door open it all leads to a dramatic
confrontation what just happened
my photographer got smacked on the side
of the head
we had confronted a person that our dark
web expert believes is linked to this
murder for hire site and possibly Yura
himself we met on a public streets and I
asked some very pointed questions and
you have to watch this show to see how
the course of that conversation went on
and what the photographer is okay he his
forehead was cut and we left shortly
thereafter and it was it's fascinating
to watch this back and forth with this
with this person it's very scary stuff
theater it is Peter thank you very much
you can see Peters report find Europe
manhunt on the dark web tomorrow night
at 10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS